Guten Tag, mein Name ist Mert. Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistentärztin tätig
und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch hören. Bitte sagen Sie mir Bescheid oder
fragen Sie nach, wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen. Zuerst brauche ich ein paar persönliche
Daten von Ihnen. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Hans Vogel. Hans Vogel, h-a-n-s ist der Vorname.
Vogel, wie? Wieder, wieder, V-M-A-Z, also V-O-G-E-L.
Okay. Herr Vogel, wie alt sind Sie? Ich bin 64.
64, wann sind Sie genau geworden? Am 16. April, 62.
Okay. Herr Vogel, wie groß sind Sie?
78. 78, wie viel wiegen Sie?
92 Kilo.
92 Kilo. Okay. Herr Vogel, wer ist Ihr Hausarzt oder Ihre Hausärztin?
Meine Hausärztin ist Frau Dr. Schmidt.
Frau Dr. Schmidt. Am Ende Doppel Tee oder Dieti?
Dieti. Dieti. Okay. Herr Vogel, was kann ich für Sie tun? Was wird Sie denn so uns?
Ach, wissen Sie, ich habe immer solche Schmerzen in meinem rechten Unterschenkel.
Also das fängt an, sobald ich ein bisschen länger gehe. Und das wird halt immer schlimmer.
Also am Anfang habe ich gar nicht, also ich konnte eigentlich immer gut marschieren und so, ne?
Und jetzt wird es eben nach einigen, ja also da bin ich noch keinen Kilometer gelaufen.
Dann tun mir mit einmal, fängt das an so zu ziehen im Unterschenkel, in der Wade und im Bein.
Und ja, das ist also wirklich dann so, dass ich eigentlich eine Pause machen muss, dann kann ich nicht weitergehen.
Wie weit können Sie laufen?
Also ich kann natürlich weitergehen, aber ich muss zwischendurch eine Pause machen.
Ja, das ist vielleicht so, also so 300 Meter oder so.
300 Meter können Sie laufen, dann müssen Sie eine Pause machen.
Ja, genau. Und die Schmerzen sind wirklich so heftig, dass man nicht weitergehen kann, ne?
Denn ich muss dann stehen bleiben.
Okay, seit wann leiden Sie unter diesen Schmerzen?
Ja, also ich habe das schon eigentlich eine ganze Weile, aber ich habe irgendwie immer gedacht, das muss auch von alleine wieder weggehen.
Dann habe ich gedacht, das sind vielleicht Krämpfe, dann habe ich mal versucht Magnesium zu nehmen.
Das hat aber auch nichts geholfen.
Und ja, jetzt habe ich dann gedacht, Mensch, das wird ja wirklich immer schlechter.
Und ja, deswegen bin ich in die Zeit gekommen.
Okay, können Sie die Schmerzen genau beschreiben? Sind die Schmerzen eher sichend oder stechend?
Es zieht, würde ich sagen. Es zieht und...
Ja, wie kann man das... Schmerzen zu beschreiben ist echt schwierig.
Stechend ist vielleicht nicht...
Du.
Also es zieht und drückt vielleicht.
Drückt.
Ja, also ich kann dann echt nicht weiterlaufen.
Also dann würde ich sagen, über die Hälfte bestimmt.
So zwischen 6, 7... 6, 7, ja, so ungefähr.
Gege, beim Laufen, haben Sie in der Ruhe auch Schmerzen? In Ruhe?
In Ruhe? Nein, nein, nein. Also wenn ich still sitze oder so geht, ist es in Ordnung.
Waren Sie deswegen beim anderen Arzt?
Nein, mein Hausarzt ist im Augenblick im Urlaub und deswegen bin ich direkt hierher gekommen.
Haben Sie außer Magnesium etwas eingenommen gegen die Schmerzen?
Ja, ich habe das mal versucht. Also, ja, also ich nehme wohl manchmal...
Wie heißt das? Ibuprofen, wenn ich Schmerzen habe, ne?
Aber das hat jetzt... Also das hilft vielleicht im Augenblick, aber beim Laufen tut es dann trotzdem wieder weh.
Ok. Kennen Sie die Dosierung?
400, 600...
Ich glaube das sind 400er, ich weiß es aber gar nicht so genau.
Ok, kein Problem. Strahlen die Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus? In den Füßen oder Oberschenkel?
Nee, eigentlich ist es so begrenzt auf den Unterschenkel würde ich sagen. Das Strahlen tut es nicht.
Sind Ihre Beine geschwollt?
Geschwollt ist mir nicht aufgefallen. Was mir aufgefallen ist, dass ich immer kalte Füße habe.
Ok, sind Ihnen Taubhaltgefühl kribbel aufgefallen?
Nee, das nicht. Es tut nur weh. Also Taubhalt eigentlich nicht. Es tut weh.
Ok, haben Sie brüchige Nagel oder schuppige Haut, trockene Haut bemerkt?
Ja, so ein bisschen trocken ist die Haut natürlich... Ja, ist die schon am Unterschenkel.
Ja, Männercreme sich ja auch nicht so oft ein wie Frauen.
Also ja, ich meine ich habe natürlich auch so diesen Alterszucker und das ist ja auch nicht so gut für die Haut.
Ok, bekommen Sie schwer Luft? Haben Sie Luftprobleme?
Nee, mit der Luft habe ich keine Probleme.
Ok, hatten Sie einen Unfall oder eine Verletzung?
Nee, dann würde ich mich ja nicht wundern, dass es mir weh tut. Aber ich hatte eben nichts.
Also so aus dem Licht sind die Schmerzen gekommen. Das hat einfach von alleine angefangen.
Und was machen Sie, wenn Sie Schmerzen haben? Zum Beispiel Tiefleigerung, Hochleigerung?
Also die Schmerzen kommen ja vor allen Dingen beim Laufen. Ich muss stehen bleiben.
Und wenn ich dann einen kleinen Moment gestanden habe, dann kann ich weitergehen.
Ok, und Herr Vögel, haben Sie viel Bauchdampfrosen?
Nee, zum Glück nicht. Ich habe mich natürlich nicht gemessen, aber ich fühle mich nicht krank.
Eigentlich ist es eben nur dieser Schmerz da.
Ok, haben Sie brüchige Nagell bemerkt?
Nein, die Fußnägel sehen in meinem Alter sowieso nicht mehr so schön aus.
Aber das ist besonders schlimm, das ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Ok, können Sie gut schlafen?
Na ja, also meistens kann ich eigentlich schon ganz gut schlafen.
Aber manchmal muss ich auch nachts schon auf die Toilette gehen.
Und dann mache ich halt kurz auf, aber dann schlafe ich eigentlich auch gut wieder ein.
Ok, wie häufig müssen Sie auf Toilette gehen?
Also vielleicht jede dritte Nacht oder so, dass ich einmal gehen muss.
Ok, Herr Vögel, haben Sie Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang oder beim Wasserlassen?
Na ja, also mit dem Stuhlgang, da muss ich schon manchmal ein bisschen nachhelfen.
Ich bin leicht ein bisschen verstopft, ja.
Nehmen Sie dagegen etwas ein?
Ja, also ich nehme dann halt so Leinsamen eingeweicht, ein bisschen oder so Flohsamen.
Das hilft eigentlich immer ganz gut.
Ok, essen Sie gern?
Ich esse gerne, ja. Sonst würde ich auch nicht so viel wiegen.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit ab oder so genommen?
Oh, ich wiege mich jetzt nicht jeden Tag, ich denke aber, also wären überhaupt eher zugenommen als abgenommen.
Aber eigentlich passen die Hosen noch alle. Also ich würde sagen, das ist jetzt ziemlich stabil.
Ist Ihnen übel, müssen Sie sich übergeben?
Um Gottes Willen, nein, bloß nicht.
Ok, Herr Vögel, jetzt möchte ich mit Ihnen über Vorerkrankungen sprechen. Davor möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, wie ich sagte, ich habe den Alterszucker.
Und was jeder hat in meinem Alter, ich habe ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck.
Und die Blutfettwerte sind auch nicht so gut, ja.
Seit wann leiden Sie an Zuckerkrankheiten?
Ja, das ist schon vor 15 Jahren aufgetreten.
Vor 15 Jahren. Was nehmen Sie dagegen ein?
Ich nehme Metformin, ne?
Metformin. Kennen Sie die Dosierung?
Das sind 850 glaube ich. Ne oder 800, ich weiß es gar nicht.
850, ja ok. Wann nehmen Sie morgens?
Einmal morgens.
Einmal morgens, ok.
Und Herr Vögel, Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Blutdruck und Blutfettwerte haben seit wann?
Können Sie mir sagen?
Ja, also mit dem Blutdruck, das hat man so vor 10 Jahren, ist es irgendwie dann ein bisschen auffällig geworden.
Wahrscheinlich war das auch schon vorher da. Aber da habe ich nie etwas genommen dagegen, ne?
Und jetzt nehme ich halt Ramitril dagegen.
Ramitril. Welche Dosierung?
Oh, wenn ich das jetzt wüsste, was da drauf steht.
Puh, also ich nehme da morgens eine und abends eine, aber ich kann Ihnen die Dosierung nicht sagen.
Aber das ist irgendwie, glaube ich, nicht so viel, was ich da nehme.
Ok. Ich kann Ihren Hausarzt kontaktieren.
Ah ja, das wäre gut. Die haben die, ja.
Und Blutfettwerte seit 10 Jahren, ja?
Ja, das hat man so zusammen festgestellt, genau.
Was nehmen Sie dagegen ein?
Da nehme ich gar nichts ein.
Sagt mein Hausarzt, ich soll ein bisschen vorsichtig essen und, aber ja, ich glaube das ist auch nicht so aufregend.
Ok. Habe ich weitere Erkrankungen?
Nee, sonst? Ich wüsste eigentlich nicht, dass ich so ein. Ich war bisher auch immer ziemlich gesund.
Ok, ja. Nehmen Sie außer diese Medikamente andere Medikamente ein? Bei Bedarf oder regelmäßig?
Ja, wie gesagt, Euoprophäen habe ich immer da, wenn man mal Kopfschmerzen hat oder ja, wenn einem auch die Knochen weht oder so.
Und dann nehme ich das schon mal.
Ok. Herr Vögel, wurden Sie schon operiert?
Ja, in der Kindheit, da habe ich mal die Mandeln rausbekommen und dann, ja natürlich, ich hatte mal einen Bandscheibenvorfall.
Und da bin ich operiert worden.
Wo genau? Im Landenbereich oder?
Ja, ja, ja, die viele Sitzerei. Ich war Lkw-Fahrer und da sitzt man halt den ganzen Tag und ja, das war wohl nicht so gut für den Rücken, ja.
Ok, ja. Wurden Sie stationär aufgenommen?
Das ist stationär gewesen, ja.
Ok. Herr Vögel, sind bei Ihnen Allergien beckert?
Ja, ich darf kein Penicillin nehmen.
Das habe ich in der Kindheit irgendwann mal festgestellt, dass ich da allergisch reagiere.
Ja, also das war noch relativ harmlos. Ich hatte dann irgendwie so einen Ausschlag und das hat gejuckt und dann hat man gesagt, oh nee, das darfst du dein Leben lang nicht mehr nehmen.
Ja, ich verstehe. Ok. Haben Sie weitere Allergien?
Nee, sonst? Wüsste ich eigentlich nicht.
Vertragen Sie Milchprodukte, Getreideprodukte, Obst oder Gemüse?
Ich kann alles essen, was ich will, ja.
Ok, gut. Herr Vögel, können Sie mir sagen, ob Sie rauen?
Kann ich Ihnen schon sagen, ja. Ich sage es aber ungern, ja. Ich rauche schon lange und ein Päckchen am Tag auf alle Fälle.
Seit wann rauen Sie?
Seit ich denken kann. Also da bestimmt 40 Jahre, ja.
40 Jahre. Haben Sie schon versucht, Rachen zu reduzieren oder aufzuhören?
Haben Sie das mal versucht? Das ist schwer. Also egal ist.
Ja, ich verstehe. Aber ok. Herr Vögel, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, also hin und wieder trinke ich schon mal Alkohol, ja. Also wir trinken, was weiß ich, abends mal ein Bier.
Ja, aber gerade im Sommer, wenn es so warm ist, natürlich klar.
Wenn es was zu feiern gibt, dann gibt es auch mal ein Glas Sekt.
Aber überwiegend trinken wir eigentlich Bier.
Und wenn es ein bisschen hoch hergeht, auch mal ein paar Schnäpse oder so.
Aber nicht jeden Tag oder so.
Geht ja gar nicht. Aber Sie trinken jeden Tag Bier, ja?
Nein, auch nicht jeden Tag.
Gelegentlich.
Ok. Herr Vögel, die nächste Frage ist eine Routinefrage.
Konsumieren Sie Drogen?
Nein, Drogen haben wir wirklich nicht.
Ok, ja gut. Was ist Ihre Familienstadt?
Ich bin verheiratet.
Verheiratet. Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, wir haben eine große Familie. Wir haben vier Kinder, aber die meisten sind schon aus dem Haus.
Es ist nur noch der Jüngste da.
Sind Ihre Kinder gesund?
Die sind alle fit und gesund, ja.
Ok, gut zu wissen, ja. Und Sie sind LKW-Fahrer, ja?
Ich bin LKW-Fahrer, ja.
Wo wohnen Sie? In einer Wohnung oder in einem Haus?
In der Wohnung, ja.
Müssen Sie Treppen steigen?
Ja, das fällt mir auch nicht so leicht. Aber noch eine Treppe hoch, ne?
Und dann haben wir dann schön eine Wohnung.
Ok. Herr Vögel, gibt es in Ihrer Familie irgendwelche Vorerkrankungen,
die Sie von denen nicht wissen sollten?
Also meine Mutter, die ist natürlich auch schon jetzt sehr, sehr alt.
Die hat auch diesen Alterszucker, ne?
Aber ansonsten müsste ich nicht. Und mein Vater, der ist, ja, der hat einen Herzinfarkt.
Der ist keine 80 Jahre alt geworden. Der war 79.
79.
Aber liegt jetzt auch schon ein paar Jahre zurück, ne?
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe drei Brüder, aber ja, also ich habe nicht so viel Kontakt zu denen.
Wissen Sie, Sie sind Ihrem Bruder gesund oder?
Ja, ich glaube, der eine hat auch diese Zuckerkrankheit und so,
aber von den anderen weiß ich nicht viel. Ich glaube nicht, dass die irgendwas haben.
Ok. Ja, Herr Vögel, das waren meine Fragen.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen?
Ja, also ich will natürlich wissen, woher die Schmerzen kommen.
Und vor allem will ich wissen, was man dagegen tun kann.
Also immer Tabletten nehmen will ich natürlich auch nicht, Schmerz-Tabletten nehmen.
Ich muss ja wieder, also ich muss noch ein paar Jahre arbeiten, bis ich in Rente gehen kann.
Und deswegen muss ich irgendwie schauen, dass ich wieder fit werde.
Ja, Herr Vögel, jetzt kann ich nicht sagen, was ich habe.
Ich würde zunächst körperliche Untersuchungen durchführen,
Blut abnehmen und ein Ultraschall durchführen.
Wenn ich alle Ergebnisse habe, dann kann ich Ihnen sagen, was Sie haben.
Ok, gut. Und was für Untersuchungen müssen Sie jetzt machen?
Ja, ich werde gleich machen.
Ja, aber was machen Sie denn da mit mir?
Ja, ich werde Ihre Beine untersuchen.
Zuerst will ich sehen, wie Ihr Bein aussieht.
Und dann werde ich beide Beine vergleichen, Ihren Puls abtasten.
Und dann Ultraschall würde ich durchführen.
Ok, na gut, das klingt ja nicht so schwierig. Alles klar, gut.
Herr Vögel, darf ich eine Frage stellen?
Aber ja.
Ist Ihnen Haarausfall am betroffenen Bein ausgefallen?
Haarausfall?
Ja, im Vergleich zur Gegenseite.
Haarausfall habe ich nicht an den Beinen, aber ich habe auch nicht so furchtbar beharte Beine.
Danke.
Gibt es sonst noch Fragen?
Nein.
Herr Vögel, haben Sie im betroffenen Bereich Blässe bemerkt?
Ja, ein bisschen heller sieht die Haut da schon aus, das stimmt.
Und haben Sie Rückenschmerzen?
Nach der Bandscheiben-OP jetzt eigentlich nicht mehr.
Also ja, wenn ich viel gearbeitet habe und lange im Auto gesessen habe, ja,
dann tut mir schon mal ein bisschen der Rücken weh, aber das ist jetzt nicht mein Hauptproblem.
Ja, verstehe, danke.
Herr Vögel, leiden Sie auch unter Wadenkrämpfe?
Ja, das habe ich ja gedacht, dass das Wadenkrämpfe sind.
Aber da müsste ja Magnesium eigentlich helfen.
Das sagt ja jeder, und es hat aber nicht geholfen.
Wo ist denn meine Ärztin hin?
Möchte jemand sonst noch irgendwas wissen?
Ach, da ist sie wieder.
Ich habe sie gerade schon vermisst.
Können wir schon weitermachen?
Ja.
Boah, sind Sie schnell. Wahnsinn.
Gut, ja. Dann lassen Sie uns gleich loslegen.
Guten Tag, ich möchte Ihnen einen neuen Patienten, Herrn Hans Vögel, vorstellen.
Er ist 64 Jahre alt, 1,78 Meter groß, 82 Kilogramm schwer.
Er stellt sich heute bei uns wegen seit Langem bestehender Rechten und Schenkelschmerzen vor.
Er beschreibt die Schmerzen als sichern und drücken.
Lauter Patienten sind die Schmerzen im Laufe der Zeit schlimmer geworden.
Die Schmerzinteresse wurde mit 6 bis 7 von 10 beim Laufen auf der Schmerzskala angegeben.
Er berichtete, er kann nach einer Geschüttrecke von 300 Meter laufen.
Dann soll er eine Pause machen und stehen bleiben.
Ah, okay. Wie nennt man das?
Klinikatrinterminanst.
Okay.
Darüber hinaus erwähnte er, dass er wegen der 5er Magnesium und Ibuprofen 400 Milligramm eingenommen hat.
Aber das hat bei ihm nicht geholfen.
Darüberhin klagte er über Kältegefühl und trockene Haut sowie blöde Haut im betroffenen Bereich.
Die Fragen nach Ödeme, Hypesthesie sowie Parastese wurden verneint.
Die vegetative Anamnese ergab Obstupation und Nikturie.
Die Anführung der Krankheit ist von folgendem bekannt.
Diabetes mellitus type 2 seit 15 Jahren.
Dagegen nimmt er mit Formen 850 Milligramm morgens ein.
Und arteriale Hypertonie seit 10 Jahren.
Und Hyperlipidemie seit 10 Jahren.
Er nimmt gegen die arteriale Hypertonie RamiPril morgens und abends ein.
Und er benutzt bei Bedarf Filosamen oder Lysamen gegen Obstupation.
Und er nimmt Ibuprofen 400 Milligramm bei Bedarf, wenn er Schmerzen hat.
Bei ihm wurde eine Translektomie in der Kindheit durchgeführt.
Und er ist wegen LVS-Diskusprolapsis operiert worden.
Penicillin Allergie ist bei ihm bekannt.
Diese Allergie äußert sich Exanthem und Pururitus.
Er braucht seit 40 Jahren Einpackung.
Und er trinkt Bia, Muchmallysekt und Schnaps.
Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Er ist verheiratet, hat vier gesunde Kinder.
Und er ist LKW-Fahrer von Beruf.
Er wohnt in seiner Wohnung.
Und er lebt mit seiner Frau und seinen jüngsten Kindern.
Die anderen sind schon aus dem Haus, ja.
Sein Vater hatte einen Myokardinfarkt mit 79.
Und seine Mutter leidet an Diabetes mellitus Typ 2.
Er hat drei Brüder.
Aber er hat keinen Kontakt zu seinem Bruder.
Aber eines von denen leidet an Diabetes mellitus.
Einer von denen, ja. Sehr gut. Okay.
Ja, die anamnestischen Angaben deuten am ersten auf PVK hin.
Differentialdiagnostik kommen TFC und Diabetesche Fußzentrum in Betracht.
Ah ja, genau. Und was machen Sie diagnostisch mit dem Patienten?
Worauf achten Sie dabei bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Ich könnte sich trockene Haut und tropische Störungen vielleicht zeigen.
Dann würde ich palpieren.
Im betroffenen Bereich palpieren.
Ob es eine Ödeme vorliegt.
Ob Ödeme vorliegen, ja.
Hauttemperatur würde ich bestimmen.
Puls würde ich abtasten.
Welchen Puls?
Arterie dorsalis pedis, arterie tibialis posterior, arterie poplitea und arterie femuralis würde ich abtasten.
Und beide Beine würde ich vergleichen.
Sehr gut. Okay.
Ja, dann würde ich Blut abnehmen.
Was erwarten Sie denn bei der Pulsbestimmung?
Ja, im betroffenen Bereich erwarte ich Schwäche oder keine Puls.
Genau. Okay. Gut.
Ja, dann nehmen Sie Blut ab und das bestimmen Sie im Blut?
Ja. Blutbild, CRP, BSG, Leberwerte, Nierenwerte, Elektrolyte sowie Blutzucker
und HBA1C und Didimere.
Ach so, ja bestimmt. Der hat ja Diabetes, genau.
Ja, und Didimere würde ich bestimmen.
Ja, sehr gut.
Und würde ich ein Ultraschall durchführen.
Mit Ultraschall würde ich überprüfen, ob eine Thrombose oder Stenose vorliegt.
Und dann würde ich Knochenarmindex berechnen.
Knochenarmindex, sehr gut. Ja, okay.
Und ja, wenn sich das jetzt bestätigt, dass der wirklich einen abgeschwächten Puls hat
und eine reduzierte Durchblutung in dem Bein, wie wäre dann das Therapieschema?
Ja, bei bestätigung meiner Verdacht Diagnose würde ich folgende Therapie verordnen.
Ich würde so eine Schmerzadaptierte Therapie einleiten.
Der Patient sollte die Risikofaktoren vermeiden, wie zum Beispiel Nikotinkarenz,
Alkoholkarenz sowie seine Blutzucker, Blutdruck und Blutfettwerte gut einstellen.
Ja oder kontrollieren auf alle Fälle.
Ja, und ich würde Physiotherapie, Gehtraining empfehlen.
Gehtraining, ja sehr gut, okay.
Ja, und je nach Stadium würde ich die Therapie einleiten.
Hier kam gerade schon ein Hinweis, medikamentös, was würden Sie da machen?
Ja, ich würde Stazine und Aspirin anfangen.
Sehr gut, ja, ja, okay, gut. Sie haben von den Stadien gesprochen, welche Stadien der PAVK kennen Sie?
Fontaine, Fontaine Steine, es wird in vier Gruppen eingeteilt.
Stadium 1, Stadium 1 leichte Schmerzen.
Ja oder fast keine, ne?
Fast keine oder leichte Schmerzen. Stadium 2.
Stadium 2, Stadium 1 keine Schmerzen. Stadium 2 Schmerzklinik für Intermittent, eigentlich.
Und 2A und 2B. 2A kann der Patient über 200 Meter laufen.
2B, der Patient unter 200 Meter laufen.
Sehr gut, okay, ja.
Und Stadium 3, Ruheschmerzen. Stadium 4, es gibt tropische Veränderungen, Necrose oder Verletzungen.
Okay, ja, also bei der PAVK kann man Ihnen nichts vormachen.
Das wissen Sie sehr gut Bescheid.
Gut, ja, dann halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden, was rauskommt bei Ihren Untersuchungen.
Und dann, wie wir den Herrn Vogel weiter behandeln müssen. Vielen Dank.
Ja, also das war eine ausgezeichnete Anamnese und ein sehr guter Bericht, auch würde ich sagen.
Sie sprächten grammatikalisch ausgesprochen korrektes Deutsch, also wirklich super.
Sie machen, glaube ich, überhaupt gar keine Fehler. Was ein bisschen gewöhnungsbedürftig ist,
Sie machen so eine ganz, ja Sie haben nicht so ganz viel Sprachmelodie drin.
Sie sprechen sehr exakt, aber es gibt eigentlich nicht viel Betonung in Ihren Sätzen oder in Ihren Wörtern.
Das geht so sehr gleichförmig. Und wir neigen ja eher dazu, wenn wir Muttersprachler sind,
dass wir so ein bisschen mehr Musik reinbringen in die Sätze.
Aber das ist eigentlich nur so, dass man raushört, dass Sie eben keine Muttersprachlerin sind.
Aber richtig und gut verständlich ist es immer noch. Ja, also überhaupt kein Ding.
Und Sie haben eigentlich sehr konsequent Ihre Fragen gestellt und haben dann auch gezielt weiter gefragt.
In die Richtung, wo Sie gemerkt haben, da geht es lang. Ja, das sind die Beschwerden.
Was könnte Ursache sein? Haben Sie gezielt nach weiteren Symptomen gefragt?
Und haben dann die anderen Fragen eigentlich ja auch so ein bisschen, ja zwar kurz angerissen.
Ja, zum Beispiel Fieber und kardiale Beschwerden oder so.
Aber das lag ja eigentlich auf der Hand, dass das nicht das Hauptthema war hier bei diesen Patienten.
Und das fand ich auch schon mal sehr gut, dass Sie da konsequent eigentlich nur in die richtige Richtung weitergefragt haben.
Und genau das haben Sie auch nachher weiter gemacht im Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch.
Sie haben sich eigentlich sehr konsequent an Ihren Fahrplan gehalten.
Sie haben nicht viel umgestellt sozusagen, sondern Sie haben den Ablauf eigentlich schön geschildert.
Was man vielleicht noch dazu sagen sollte, ja in diesem ersten Satz haben Sie gesagt,
er hat sich wegen Schmerzen in den Unterschenkel vorgestellt.
Aber diese Schmerzen sind ja nicht permanent, sondern er hat sich eigentlich mit dieser klassischen Clauulicatio Intermittens vorgestellt.
Das könnte man fast schon praktisch sagen, ja, beziehungsweise er hat sich vorgestellt mit Schmerzen,
die beim Laufen nach einer Gehstrecke von circa 300 Meter auftreten.
Das wäre vielleicht noch die einzige Ergänzung und eine winzigkeit, ja eine winzige Zahl.
Ich habe gesagt, ich wiege 92 Kilo und Sie haben einfach 82 Kilo draus gemacht.
Nicht, dass Sie 10 Kilo weniger gesagt haben, aber wie gesagt eigentlich hat er gesagt 92.
Ja, der ist halt A-übergewichtig, hat den Diabetes Typ 2, hat einen erhöhten Blutdruck,
hat eigentlich erhöhte Cholesterinwerte wie alle in dem Alter und mit dem Gewicht und er raucht.
Das ist natürlich einer der Hauptrisikofaktoren für die PAVK, ist ja klar.
Gut, ja und natürlich hat sie den Typ in der PAVK, ist ja richtig.
Ja und auch die Differenzalien haben mir auch gut gefallen, dass Sie gesagt haben ja TVD
und was man vielleicht noch sagen könnte, dass der möglicherweise nochmal wieder neuen Bandscheibenvorfall
oder irgendwie da Probleme hat, aber dann würden die Schmerzen eigentlich nicht erst im Unterschenkel sein,
sondern würden eigentlich das ganze Bein betreffen.
Ja, aber also in meinen Augen war das eine sehr, sehr gute Anamnese und ein sehr guter Bericht.